werde ich 100 Tage ohne Supermarkt
überleben du bist ja eine starke Frau
aber 100 Tage ohne echten Tee oder
Kaffee halt ich nicht durch du auch
nicht ich glaube du schaffst die 100
Tage mit selbst angebauten selbst
gesammelten und selbst Gejagten
Lebensmittel ich könnte mir vorstellen
dass es irgendwann ja ein bisschen
eintönig teilweise wird wie viele
Kartoffeln hast du noch im Keller ich
habe die Kartoffeln noch nicht geerntet
aber ich gehe davon aus dass es sehr
wenig sind weiße trocken war ist halt
die Frage wie krass du in dem bist wenn
du sagst ich habe hungern leg mich jetzt
ins Bett
kurz erstmal zu den Regeln ich werde
weiterhin Salz essen also das ist meine
eine Ausnahme dann habe ich einen Liter
Öl den ich über die 100 Tage hinweg mir
irgendwie einteilen muss und die dritte
Regel bezieht sich auf meinen
Vorratsschrank den ich jetzt schon habe
das sind fast alles selber angebaute
Lebensmittel aber wenn ich jetzt zum
Beispiel so ein Glas Kirschen habe dann
habe ich da ja Zucker zugefügt beim
Einkochen und der Zucker war natürlich
gekauft also setze ich mir die Regel das
in Sachen die ich vor der Challenge
haltbar gemacht habe wo vielleicht so
ein paar gekaufte Zutaten drin sind dass
ich diese Lebensmittel weiterhin auch
während der Challenge essen kann was
glaubt ihr denn werde ich das schaffen
oder ist das unrealistisch oder wie hart
wird es falls ich es durchhalten kann
Weihnachten wird hart es werden auf
jeden Fall auf dem Kanal hier hochkant
Videos kommen die ein bisschen kürzer
sind wo ich euch mal im Alltag mitnehme
und dann auch längere ausführlichere
Videos bevor ich euch erzähle wie es mir
so ergeht also folgt dem Kanal wenn ihr
das mitverfolgen wollt ansonsten darf
ich in den 100 Tagen auch Lebensmittel
die ich selber angebaut oder erzeugt
habe mit anderen Leuten die auch etwas
selber gemacht haben tauschen aber nur
zu einem fairen Preis ich kann jetzt
nicht ein Ei gegen sagen wir ziehen
Gläser Honig eintauschen also es muss
schon ein realistischer und fairer Deal
sein die Idee dass ich das machen will
habe ich schon länger aber ich habe
immer gedacht jetzt passt es gerade
nicht jetzt habe ich gerade eine große
Rattenplage zum Beispiel in meinem
Garten wo ich quasi nichts mehr Ernte
also die Ratten Klettern an den
Tomatenpflanzen hoch und fressen die
Tomaten auf bevor sie überhaupt richtig
Geld werden geschweige denn rot das
heißt ich habe dieses Jahr fast keine
Tomatenernte gehabt kennt ihr euch das
vorstellen die haben meine komplette
brokkoli-ernte einfach abrasiert und die
Kohlrabi Pflanzen die ich hatte sind an
mehreren Seiten angenagt so dass das
bisschen was in der Mitte noch stehen
geblieben ist einfach wirklich nicht
mehr lecker aussieht sprechen wir noch
mal über Kartoffeln weil ich glaube dass
die in so einer Challenge super super
wichtig sind weil Kartoffeln viele
Kohlenhydrate enthalten und ich glaube
die Kohlenhydrate werden mein Knackpunkt
während der Challenge sein ich habe im
Moment ungefähr zehn Kilo Kartoffeln die
ich schon geerntet aber noch nicht
aufgegessen habe ich habe aber noch zwei
Beete Kartoffeln im Garten an die ich
noch gar nicht rangegangen bin und da
bin ich sehr gespannt drauf weil ich
glaube dass die Ernte auf diesen Beeten
nicht besonders gut ausfallen wird ich
habe schon mal ein bisschen gelusert an
zwei Pflanzen und sie schon mal
rausgezogen mal ein bisschen geguckt und
da waren sehr wenige und sehr kleine
Kartoffeln dran es kann mit der
Trockenheit Zusammenhängen ich weiß es
nicht auf jeden Fall mache ich mir keine
großen Hoffnungen dass ich da noch eine
dicke Ernte bekomme aber ich nehme euch
natürlich mit wenn es daran geht die
Kartoffeln auszugraben das wird auf
jeden Fall für mich sehr sehr spannend
und glaube ich auch sehr entscheidend
werden früher habe ich Ziegen gemolken
und meine eigenen Käse und Joghurt und
so weiter gemacht das fällt jetzt aber
auch komplett weg ich wollte darüber im
Internet eigentlich gar nicht sprechen
aber
meine zie wurden auf der Weide getötet
also mehrere und da sind auch andere
schreckliche Sachen passiert also
wirklich furchtbare Sachen mit
Brandstiftung und so weiter und
ja das ist ein ja ich möchte da gar
nicht weiter drüber reden aber ich habe
auf jeden Fall jetzt keine Ziegen mehr
und ich glaube wenn ich weiter
Milchprodukte hätte wäre die Challenge
um einiges leichter aber ich will jetzt
hier nicht so pessimistisch sein also
ich freue mich auch unfassbar doll das
jetzt anzugehen und ich glaube ich werde
so viel Neues werden und ich werde mein
Horizont so erweitern Nüsse habe ich zum
Glück richtig richtig viele also sowohl
Haselnüsse als auch Walnüsse und das hat
mich auf jeden Fall in den letzten Tagen
sehr arg beruhigt zu wissen dass ich
Nüsse habe die ich im Zweifel auch zu
mir malen kann und dir auf jeden Fall
satt machen nächste Woche kommt auf
meinem Kanal eine komplette
Vorratskammer Tour mit dem Stand jetzt
wir haben die aufgenommen einen Tag
bevor es mit der Challenge los ging und
da führe ich euch durch alle Vorräte die
ich hier habe und zeige euch mit welchem
Vorrat ich jetzt in die Challenge
startete ein Punkt über den sich ein
paar Leute sorgen gemacht haben mein
Sohn muss natürlich nicht mitmachen also
ich habe mir so in der erst 8 Jahre alt
und der darf natürlich weiterhin
Schokolade essen und alle möglichen
anderen Sachen die er essen möchte ich
werde auch weiterhin ganz normal für
meinen Sohn einkaufen gehen also bitte
wünscht mich nicht wenn ihr mich im
Supermarkt trefft weil er natürlich
weiterhin alles bekommt genauso wie mein
Freund weiterhin ganz normal ist das
wird glaube ich auch sehr hart für die
Jungs zu kochen wenn ich davon überhaupt
nichts essen kann ich werde Pizza so
vermissen ich habe gestern Abend noch
eine Tiefkühlpizza gegessen als
Kontrastprogramm und so kleinen kleines
Fest bevor es richtig losgeht mit der
Challenge ich habe außerdem vor zwei
Jahren glaube ich ein Video darüber
gemacht was ich glaube wie eine
hundertprozentige Selbstversorgung
funktionieren könnte ich glaube das ist
super spannend wer jetzt noch mal zu
gucken was ich damals dazu zu sagen
hatte ohne einen Plan dass jemals selber
in die Tat umzusetzen also schaut gerne
da drüben vorbei ansonsten geht raus
macht die Welt ein bisschen grüner und
wir sehen uns bald wieder mit einem
Update und wish me luck